we're now on problem number seven file
number 7 says x equals one-half or if
equals x equals one-half what is the
value of 1 over X plus 1 over X minus 1
so 1 over X well that's just one over
one half plus one over what's X minus
one what's one half minus one what's
minus one half right so this is X minus
1 is minus one half and this looks I
mean you could evaluate it or you can
immediately see that these would cancel
out because you can take this minus and
put it right here and make this a plus
or you could evaluate it and say well
this is equal to 2 minus 2 and that
equals 0 so this is just kind of a speed
question to see how fast you can do it
how much time do you waste on this okay
problem number 8 i'll do it in green see
let me draw that so I'm going to
coordinate axes oh my god edit an undue
coordinate axes I didn't have my line
tool lon and that's the x axis this is
the y axis then let me draw some points
here I have to point right here and they
say this is 1 comma 0 the x-axis that's
the y-axis and still use the line tool
then let's go straight up like this like
that
right angle there right angle there this
is point s this is point t this is point
are they say the figure above RS RS is
equal to s T so RS is equal to st that's
I'm saying that their lengths are equal
and the coordinates of s the coordinate
of s right here is K comma 3 K comma 3
so what does that tell us that means
that the x value right here this point
right here is K and this Y value right
here is 3 all right K comma 3 that's not
t3 that's I'm just saying the Y value
right here is 3 what is the value of K
well we know that this length and this
length are the same right so we know
that what is this length what is this
length that it has a very ugly curly
bracket but we know that the Y value we
know the value value here is 3 right
this intersects the y intercept at three
right here so this we know that distance
is three we know that this distance is
three that's also three and we also know
that this is equal to this so we also
know that this distance is three and
that distance is three we know this
distance is three but we're three to the
left we're three to the left of the y
axis right where we've gone three units
in the negative direction so the value
of K or the x-coordinate here would be
negative three cuz we went three to the
left it was out here would be positive 3
or since here it's negative 3 and that's
choice a next question number nine
number nine okay so they draw up let's
see they say so they drew a table and
I'll just pull out I'll write it the way
they did it so they did X and f of X
and then they say 0 1 2 3 1 2 5 10 the
table above give the valves the values
of the quadratic function f for the
selected values of x which of the
following defines F so it's a quadratic
function so we know it's going to you
know have the form you know f of X is
going to be something like x squared
well it could be ax squared plus BX plus
C my suspicions though is it's going to
be something fairly simple so let's see
you know the way I would do without play
around with it so if I squared this x
value right and I still end up with a 1
and this is actually the biggest clue
right here because when x is 0 f of X is
1 so we know that this constant term is
going to be one it's going to be
something plus one because when x is 0
these things are equal to 0 this ax
squared plus BX and we still have it
equal to 1 so we don't see is 1 so we
know that already that it's ax squared
plus BX plus 1 and then let's see we
know that we have a plus one here right
so we know this this whole term is going
to you know you put it you could put it
in here but when you get a plus one well
I'm explaining it very confusing way but
your brain might just say hey if I
Square this and add this plus one I get
to if I Square this and I add one I get
five if I squared three and I had one i
get 10 and you would so say say well f
of x is much too much just equal x
squared plus one if your brain doesn't
just stumble on that although it should
you should probably just say but it's
probably something simple like i squared
and i add one or subtract one because
they're never going to give you
something really complicated but if they
did or if I guess if you're not doing
this and on the s80 hopefully you see
how I immediately got at the y intercept
is 1 because when x is 0 f of X is 1 and
then you could have said well when X is
1 f of X is 2 so you could have
substituted here you could set 2 is
equal to a x 81 sorry you could say 2 is
equal to 8
times 1 squared plus B times 1 plus 1
right and then you because I just
substituted act 1 for X and then I put f
of X is equal to 2 and then you would
get if you subtract 1 from both sides
you get 1 is equal to a plus B all right
and one I mean you know on the SCT
they're not going to give some crazy
fractional thing and I'm actually
hesitant to even going this whole
direction because i think it's just over
complicating the thing because you could
then do the same thing with two and five
and then get a system of equations
excedrin you would have wasted a lot of
time the big discovery here is that most
things the SCT are going to be a really
simple equation and frankly more than
doing this since it's multiple choice i
just realized you could just try out the
equations that they gave you and it's
lucky that the first one works actually
you should just try out all of them and
see which one's work next problem write
me a message if you found that last
explanation a little confusing I just
didn't want to show you kind of the
correct way to do it because that would
take you forever and it's not really the
correct way to do it on the s.a.d
problem number 10 how old was a person
exactly one year ago if exactly X years
ago the person was why years old so this
is just something to confuse you so
let's say the person so X years ago the
person was why years old so let's let's
put it this way let's so let's say what
let me say that when it's so X X years
ago so when X is let me let me think of
the best way to write this so let's
write their current age let's write the
current age is equal well let's just
write it is equal to a so we know a
couple of things we know that a minus X
is equal to Y or we know that their
current age is equal to X plus y right
this is their current age and what do we
want to figure out we
want to figure out their age one year
ago so we want to figure out their
current age minus one so the current age
minus 1 well the current age is X plus y
so you just substitute that back in and
you get X plus y minus 1 is there is how
old they were one year ago X plus y
minus one that's choice e next problem
actually I only have a minute left so
I'll do the next problem in the next
video I'll see you soon